[Música]
lindas montañas
te vieron nacer
el inba ni tú con una misión
y la cantuta su alma te dio comida
tenías que ser
linda suelta de bella mujer ojos muy
negros del mundo mirar y labios rojos
que incitan a amar tenías que ser
[Música]
como están
[Aplausos]
cuántos de nosotros cuántos de ustedes
han reído o han llorado alguna vez
escuchando una canción levanten la mano
está bien hay que ser honestos todos no
es cierto
básicamente de eso trata la charla de
hoy porque lo que pasa con el arte es
que genera empatía y que es la empatía
la empatía es básicamente sentir lo que
siente el otro ponerse en el lugar del
otro
y que es el otro
el otro es el reflejo de uno mismo
el otro es básicamente uno en otra vida
entonces si entendemos la vida y la
sociedad como un auto reconocimiento nos
damos cuenta de que probablemente si
estamos todos viviendo la vida de todos
al mismo tiempo y es por eso que el arte
es tan importante porque llega
directamente a la sensibilidad de las
personas ayuda al razonamiento pero no
directamente a la razón pero si a través
de la sensibilidad y cuando el arte es
honesto el alcance que tiene puede ser
infinito
y a qué me refiero con honestidad
básicamente a hablar de una realidad que
sí hemos vivido no inventarnos una falsa
realidad sino hablar de algo que nos ha
pasado algo que hemos sentido y que nos
ha hecho ser felices o ser tristes para
esto les doy un ejemplo
herbie hancock es un pianista
norteamericano y él siempre decía que su
comunidad lo criticaba mucho y decía por
qué no hablas de la realidad
afroamericana en tu música porque hace
es básicamente música para blancos y él
decía que puedo hablar yo
si no he estado preso de pronto no he
trabajado en campos de algodón etcétera
que puedo decir yo que sea honesto desde
mi propia realidad
entonces un día siempre juicios decidió
sentarse en el porche de su casa y ver a
la gente pasar
y en uno de esos momentos encontró a una
mujer que estaba vendiendo sandías
y esta mujer tenía un grito ofreciendo
las sandías que era básicamente algo
como guatemala guatemala algo así
eurofer y a partir de eso obviamente es
el viajan con un genio musical
[Música]
no
esta canción
es ahora una de las canciones estándar
de jazz más conocidas al alrededor del
mundo ha sido interpretada de
interpretada y así sucesivamente
entonces para que se den cuenta un poco
de cuán importante es ser honesto en el
arte
yo canto hace hace siete años
desde los siete años y profesionalmente
hace como diez once años
y he pasado por básicamente todos los
géneros que se puedan imaginar he
cantado desde laura pausini hasta don
mars volta que es rock progresivo hecho
ya has hecho pop hecho funk hecho música
electrónica de cantado folclor también y
para muchas personas eso puede
significar que no me define que no tengo
un estilo que no tengo un género que que
si yo para mí eso es justamente
descubrir a la música en todos sus
aspectos y descubrir diferentes culturas
porque cuando uno se da cuenta y escucha
una canción está escuchando también a la
persona que le ha escrito y está
escuchando también el lugar
sociocultural del que esa persona viene
no es lo mismo por ejemplo escuchar una
bossa nova
como la garota de ipanema por ejemplo es
jodida qué cosa más linda mariachi casa
y en la mínima que ve y qué pasa nunca
se iba la su camino del mar
así su hábito es un susurro es algo que
te invita a como tom jobin seguramente
estaba en la playa tomando agua de coco
y vio una chica súper guapa pasando por
ahí dijo de alguna canción es
completamente opuesto a escuchar un
grito revolucionario feminista como
sin dilo pero en los ochentas rasgándose
las vestiduras y poniéndose las cosas
así no entonces completamente opuesto y
yo sé que todos aquí conocemos estas
melodías o las hemos escuchado alguna
vez y de pronto nos gustan o no nos
gustan pero las tenemos ahí porque
porque justamente la melodía es lo que
genera recuerdos
y hay un ejercicio muy lindo que se
llama la banda sonora de mi vida que los
invito a todos a hacerlo en sus casas a
mí me lo hicieron para una entrevista
pero me pareció fabuloso porque descubrí
muchísimas cosas de cómo la música te
acompaña
y básicamente es escoger una canción en
relación a las edades que has ido
viviendo y se van a dar cuenta de lo
maravilloso que es como la música nos ha
ido acompañando y nos ha hecho depronto
madurar y nos hace recordar amigos a
personas viajes amores y siempre está
ahí siempre ha sido muy compañeras
es importante creo para todos
preguntarnos por qué hacemos lo que
hacemos y yo en algún punto empecé a
preguntarme por qué estoy aquí cantando
jazz en bolivia en vez de qué sé yo
haberme ido a estudiar acciones poco así
como la mayoría de los de mí de mi cole
y por qué estoy aquí haciendo música
cuando bolivia es un país difícil
todavía en cuanto al arte se refiere yo
creo que somos un país tenemos que
aceptar muy conservador en cuanto a
ciertas cosas se refiere como el arte
por ejemplo y yo aquí cantando jazz en
bolivia
nos encontramos con muchísimas barreras
nos encontramos con un gusto masivo que
de pronto es más tirado a lo popular al
folklore oral a la cumbia que se yo
podría tranquilamente yo ser la águila
boliviana si yo uso flores
amo a hilda por si acaso no
entonces me empecé a preguntar que
estaba haciendo
y si si quería seguir haciendo lo que
estaba haciendo y dije sí y mil veces si
quiero cantar esta es mi vida lo voy a
seguir haciendo siempre entonces ahí
dije por qué que estoy entregando yo que
estoy haciendo yo por mi sociedad siendo
esta persona que soy ahora
y allí de a poquito fue como que me vino
a esta palabra empatía
y porque me di cuenta de esto gracias a
ustedes básicamente gracias al público
toda la gente que iba a los conciertos y
luego me escribía algo y me decía me
encantó pude compartir la sala dedica mi
novio y cosas hiciera como guau
estoy haciendo algo en estas personas
que de pronto yo no me imaginaba que
podía suceder hay una cita del postino
el cartero que dice que básicamente
la poesía no es para quien la escribe
sino para quien la necesita y eso me
parece fabuloso porque básicamente dice
porque hacemos arte el mensaje es
recibido pero quien le da el significado
es la persona a la que le llega el
mensaje quien lo necesita nosotros
entregamos algo y eso luego genera la
empatía y ahí se da el verdadero
significado del arte la empatía es muy
importante porque creo que lo que hace
es justamente unirnos como seres humanos
y generar respeto y lo más importante en
una sociedad es el respeto si no hay
respeto tenemos violencia ya sabemos
cómo somos nosotros muchas veces los
bolivianos como que nos auto saboteamos
nos pasamos la luz en roja tiramos la
basura en la calle atropellamos cebras
son cosas que muchas veces tenemos que
darnos cuenta que estamos haciendo mal y
hay un proyecto muy hermoso en
venezuela- que lo creó el padre abreu
que básicamente era hacer orquestas
juveniles para niños y jóvenes en
situación de calle
no se imaginan como la violencia de
creció en estos lugares con el simple
hecho de de darle una nueva motivación a
estos jóvenes a través del aprendizaje
de un instrumento era increíble como
todos estos niños tenían una nueva
motivación estaba todo redireccionado y
no permitía que se genere un carácter
violento les cuento sobre una cultura
una tribu en el áfrica lo que las madres
hacen es cuando deciden tener un hijo se
van a un bosque un poco alejado y van y
esperan que el árbol y el cielo les
mande una canción para sus hijos
entonces cuando les manda esta canción
ellas ya saben cuál va a ser la esencia
de su hijo cuál va a ser la personalidad
y le cantan esta canción todo el tiempo
es cumpleaños cuando cuando deciden
hacerle un festejo cuando les va mal
etcétera y es una canción que los
acompaña es básicamente un festejo
lo mismo pasa el primer llanto de un
bebé el primer grito de un bebé está
comunicando y eso es porque la voz del
arte es infinita y puede ser pictórica
puede ser escrita es más allá de la
vibración de cuerdas y aire no
esta que les voy a mostrar ahora es para
mí una canción que ejemplifica
totalmente cómo es que la música une y
cómo es que la música es comunicación y
cómo es que la música no discrimina y
genera comunidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en ese bar
bolivia
[Música]
para mí bolivia gana y se va al mundial
es el mejor ejemplo de cómo esta familia
porque era una familia eran los padres y
los hijos creando un mensaje de unidad
más allá del himno más allá de viva mi
patria bolivia era un momento en el que
los que nos gustaban o no nos gustaba el
fútbol o lo que sea estábamos cantando
esta canción el mundial del 94 ha sido
trascendental creo con esta canción
ahora por qué
por qué es tan importante todo esto
porque creo que es la única manera de
generar comunicación entre las personas
en la música el diálogo en el jazz por
ejemplo es una de las cosas más
importantes que existe porque los
músicos siempre se tienen que estar
comunicando y yo tengo que estar
escuchando lo que está haciendo el
bajista o lo que está haciendo el
baterista para poder responderle
básicamente hay una parte en el jazz en
la que hay solos no entonces el
guitarrista tiene un sol pero para que
el guitarrista haga ese solo necesita
una base que lo soporte y que lo ayude a
brillar
básicamente entonces no estás solo en tu
solo
para william borox los artistas son los
verdaderos arquitectos del cambio yo
creo que es muy importante que nos demos
cuenta de la importancia del arte de
cómo genera empatía como la empatía
genera respeto como el respeto baja la
violencia y como todo esto puede ser tan
sencillo como
entender un poco el mensaje de la música
el melodía
tesla nikola tesla decía que los
secretos del universo se esconden
básicamente y se entienden a través de
energía frecuencia y vibración y estos
tres elementos son básicamente los
elementos que componen a la música
otra de las cosas que es importante es
hacer tenemos que hacer muchas cosas
como músicos tenemos que crear y para
poder ser hay que hacer me encanta esta
cita porque es muy muy musical
es bueno sinatra había una antigua
era marilyn monroe de paso
esto es una cita que conocí a través de
patti smith que es una gran música
cantante con un mensaje maravilloso pero
es william bordes igual
básicamente dice construye un buen
nombre mantén tu nombre tu nombre limpio
no te comprometas no te preocupes por
hacer un montón de dinero o ser exitoso
preocúpate por hacer un buen trabajo
protege tu trabajo y si construyes un
buen nombre eventualmente este nombre
tendrá su propio valor
creo que esto es una frase que nos ayuda
en todos los aspectos de la vida para
poder trabajar por la motivación que es
la pasión y no necesariamente la
economía monetaria porque a través de la
música lo que generamos es más que nada
una economía emocional por eso es que
para mí ser exitosa en la música es
generar empatía es poder lograr que la
voz sea mi instrumento de empatía
finalmente para terminar
quiero contarles que está yo sé que la
conocen muchos de ustedes es una banda
que ha marcado no sólo por el nivel
musical sino también por el mensaje que
ha transmitido y en una de sus canciones
dicen o we need you tube skip talking
todo lo que necesitamos es seguir
hablando yo les digo o win it don't skip
singing gracias
[Música]